[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo en
france 24 mi nombre es juan pupiales
gracias por estar con nosotros
el vaticano introdujo este martes el
delito de pedofilia en su código de
derecho canónico era precisamente una de
las peticiones de estos abusos que le
reclamaban que las víctimas de sus
abusos que reclamaban a la santa sede y
se considera como uno de los cambios más
importantes sobre esa normativa que se
hace en 40 años lo que busca el papá
francisco es revisar la disciplina penal
para agilizar y endurecer las penas
contra los sacerdotes que realicen estos
crímenes y prestar más atención a las
indemnizaciones
esta revisión venía trabajándose desde
2009 e involucra a todas las 66
secciones el derecho canónico y entrará
en vigor desde el próximo 8 de diciembre
en españa un juez en rechazo a prisión
preventiva para brahím ghali líder del
frente polisario el movimiento de
liberación saharaui quien se encuentra
hospitalizado en el norte del territorio
ibérico y cuya situación ha
desencadenado una crisis diplomática
entre madrid y rabat
galli acusado de crímenes de lesa
humanidad defendió su inocencia negó
haber realizado torturas en el sáhara
occidental él llegó a españa con el
consentimiento del gobierno de pedro
sánchez algo sobre lo que marruecos ha
pedido transparencia en este contexto a
mediados de mayo unos 10.000 migrantes
llegaron al enclave español de ceuta
fronterizo con el territorio marroquí
ante la complacencia de rabat en una
maniobra calificada como inaceptable
como el presidente por el presidente
pedro sánchez
el primer ministro de canadá ya están
jugó dijo que buscar más bolsas comunes
es una parte importante para descubrir
la verdad esto después del hallazgo de
la semana pasada de restos de 215 niños
indígenas en la columbia británica bajo
la que llegó a ser una de las escuelas
más grandes del país sin embargo pudo no
realizó ningún compromiso concreto al
respecto mientras que grupos indígenas
le piden una búsqueda a nivel nacional
en más centros educativos para
determinar si hay más fosas comunes
debajo de las escuelas
en el salvador la justicia concedió la
libertad a sarah rogel una mujer
condenada a 30 años de cárcel por un
aborto que fue tipificado como homicidio
sin embargo la fiscalía anunció una
apelación que impidió la salida
inmediata de sara del ministerio público
tiene ahora cinco días para apelar y
podría llevar a un retraso de más de un
mes en la liberación de sarah ella tiene
28 años y lleva en prisión desde 2012
cuando tenía 8 meses de embarazo
en ese entonces sufrió una hemorragia
tras un accidente doméstico y para las
autoridades es una sospecha de aborto
vamos a colombia en donde se registró
una masacre en una localidad del
suroeste del país nueve personas fueron
asesinadas con un arma de fuego en una
finca de algeciras en el departamento
del huila entre las víctimas se
encuentran empleados de esta residencia
en la que ya hace un año se registró
otro hecho similar que dejó cuatro
muertos entre ellos un menor de edad el
ministro de defensa diego molano anunció
el envío de militares y policías para
investigar los hechos
este martes se espera que el gobierno de
brasil confirme si finalmente será la
sede de la copa américa de fútbol que
empieza en 12 días en la noche del lunes
el ministro de gabinete afirmó que no
estaba confirmada al 100% la celebración
del certamen en este país y es que horas
después de que la confederación
sudamericana de fútbol le asignará la
sede a brasil en detrimento de argentina
varios ejecutivos estatales y expertos
médicos expresaron su rechazo a la copa
teniendo en cuenta que en la nación de
462.000 muertos y hay más de 16 millones
y medio de casos de kobe 19 especiales
incertidumbre desde el gobierno ya
tienen claro algunas condiciones para la
eventual celebración cuando tenemos un
acuerdo de este encuentro entre nosotros
y la federación brasileña a través de
una videollamada serán diez equipos
divididos en dos grupos 65 personas por
delegación
todos deben estar vacunados esa es
nuestra demanda para la federación no
hay un documento firmado entre las
partes solo estas negociaciones la
selección brasileña también será vacuna
los hombres y líderes también será
apasionado
que siempre has 24